live it has been a heck of a few days
here Pokemon result is finally
out we've got The Hacker News
Post and it is also on X right
now so come check this
out I'll answer some questions on here
probably if people jump in but um for
the
meantime we have two main things that we
need to catch up on
today a little bit of porting
work or some
collaborators and we need to oops let's
not lead to
that hang on let me just flip this so I
can move
that close all the boring
windows and and
there
so the other thing we had to do is look
at the new oblations and figure out what
is going on with
these actually I'm just drop one thing
in Discord as well
in so I figure this is funny this has
been taking up a lot of spare time
lately but we finally got this put
together
so cluster garage gym setup happy with
this anyways what we're going to do
today uh first thing is going to be to
figure out some stuff with the
experiments that I haven't had time to
do lately and then after that we're
going to have to do some porting of some
of the optimizations we came up
with so let me see here we
have this is the current
best parito front on breakout right
and not sure what this is I think I was
just testing some stuff here close
this this 200 run is our best and then
187 okay so this is I think before we
made the perk
enhancements we were at 200
seconds for
solve now
runs okay so these run this is a 180ish
I
believe and then
these ones are 220 is there any
difference between these I thought I
literally just ran the same
thing uh the same thing
I believe this
is oh this is still going
hang on if this is still going it
shouldn't be right I
okay how is this possible it gets up to
like
it's up to 800
cost and this one's
cheaper maybe it just takes a while
longer I mean it's not fully optimized
yet but then why are these qualitatively
different they are qualitatively
different
right visualizing the wrong ones this is
our previous best this is with 187
samples okay so this has had more time
to
optimize so now the difference that
we're interested in here is the 118
versus 127 so with
118 we're getting some solves in the
180s and then here we're at
difference
here your branch is
commits oh this is not autoscaled
okay this is with a manual scale
so this actually does have some
substantial sweep differences
confused what is in Dev right
now I think we're going to want to have
Auto scale in Dev
so we're solving but it's taking way too
long
silly yes I did just delete the repo and
reclone it instead of bothering with
will leave
that and otherwise we'll just delete all
these scale terms
now we still have some issues here
right I want to see not this one this
one got screwed up
right we have
187 aut scale P30 okay so we want
this there one
comparison it's the other comparison
here right
I believe this was
pre optimization though wasn't it so we
have was it 192 is
here there we go so slightly slightly
faster but it's also fewer runs so we
expect this to come down even
more
and we go
to think
sample I want to see what the SPs is
looking
like yeah okay so there's this massive
Gap
essentially I want to understand why so
we have mini batch of 8192 here this
thing is still using two small mini
batches uh which is further slowing it
down five I think what's Just Happening
generally is that there is more
overhead in the new algorithm Branch
because it's not as well
optimized which is then preventing the
algorithm from taking advantage
of larger batch sizes and stuff because
they're they cost more and then the the
smaller batch sizes are also slower in
wall clock so you're kind of just
screwed on multiple different angles
when you have
that so I think what we want to do
here is we want to actually evaluate
speed differences
with some reasonable
settings yeah let's do
that I want to do this on
zero on my local I think we'll do this
on my local so I can play with
Bel so no Cuda GPU is available lovely I
got to reboot my container I guess
train okay so here we have our default
puffer breakout parameters here uh these
are not the parameters that I think we
want
so what we should do
is did I already do
it I think I might have already done it
size
gamma yeah I think we need to combon all
this this
slower then we do these
yeah this is still nowhere near as fast
though
as as we're expecting
right we're expecting even
faster or are we
not I think we should
be we take like
21414 I really have to make uh
a better way of copying hyper
parameters rather than having to do it
manually how is this one hang I'm
confused here so this is
seconds
but
then something doesn't add up here
because if you can
it's a bit faster right and it probably
has more
M only 48
M look
like oh
ah it runs for more steps I
see I thought I said a Max
though maybe these are eval
steps okay maybe it's slightly different
well this is fine
this is not the previous run though I
think this is a new one so we'll just
copy
these these
parameters this should give us 94
seconds is it 94 seconds all the other
one's kind of better isn't it though
yeah
84 I think we'll do this one
instead this one's pretty
cool and will'll also let us test
overhead a lot better
26 we'll give it 130
solve luckily this learning rate doesn't
matter this is just whatever should
double check on that at some point
though
okay larger bat size which is you would
expect a larger batch size
is higher just a little bit higher it's
pretty close to default
Lambda surprisingly pretty close to what
you would
expect uh by
defaults learning
rate o6
size and I can confirm that these are
way closer to Hardware optimal
settings but two update EPO is wipes get
slowed
down two update EPO is why I just
slowed let's do get rid of this
very smooth
learning very smooth
mil just a little tiny bit slower than
anticipated but still very
good definitely within what we would
expect
all right
perfect now we can compare this
one uh oh are we going to have uh
instability
here okay it's
good why is it so much longer
right maybe I gave it too many
steps hang on yeah I think I gave it too
many
steps maybe it wasn't
uh 126 but yeah this this is not going
to
be yeah it's 100 Mil not 130 mil that's
why it does solve you can
see then we
will do one more just to see if uh we
get
confirmation
so okay we did this this gives
us so yep solved
here and then we'll see if this makes
any
difference there is expected to be a
little bit of instability so if it
doesn't fully solve if it gets stuck
like somewhere it's within a
reason we'll end up having to do like
average or
something ex seed average
variance this is my better this is a lot
closer to the original solve time
there's a slight difference in
the the train speed I believe
so we also actually have decent uh en
overhead now it's worth fixing
one 1100 okay yeah so there's like a 10%
speed difference or whatever no big deal
I think my single cor slightly slower
here multicore slightly faster than the
other machine something like that so
very very close in terms of
time
841 856 okay very very
simpar very very similar
here now if I do if I do nothing
but
train.
p3o
through what
happens okay so what happens is that the
speed takes a
25 plus almost 30%
haircut this is 27%
Miss so that's all of the overhead right
there is probably in
MK so we need to make that thing
faster but I want to see how the
learning curves themselves compare I
these hyper parameters are not optimized
for this they're optimized for po not
this
algorithm I want to
see how they
instability but without even like
retuning the hyper
parameters I mean this to me is
potential right this is massive massive
potential
oh yeah that is massive massive
potential right so in
samples again little bit of weirdness
but it looks like especially if we were
to retune parameters we are on par with
GPO but we are taking
a 21% compute
there hang on forward Ming
here this is very very good like
promising good
there's so much potential with
this I was starting to get worried that
like maybe I had it wrong maybe this new
algorithm wasn't like all I thought it
was but actually I really like this is
this is worth pursuing this is really
really strong evidence for
it this isn't even using gamma and
Lambda so this is two hyper Prem is
totally ignored and there there's
several things I think that we could
improve as well so the first thing then
with this m I want to
do I'm going to leave myself a good hour
and a half for porting work so I'm going
to do this for another hour and a half
and then I'll leave the time after that
for porting
work let's go figure out where to be
slow down
this 28% is a lot
off five so we're leaking about 8% of
the compute
here pretty cool to see you have this
much promise doesn't it add a new
parameter Net One nope so at the moment
kind of because it sort of is a hyper
parameter but um longer term uh you just
set that to your hidden size and you're
done it's not like like it so once we
fix a couple weird things with how we're
calculating Horizons it should end up
being the case that more will be
strictly
better and uh in practice you'll just
set it to whatever your hidden size is
so at the moment there's a quirk with it
where you need to set it small because I
haven't done masking fully correctly but
uh that will go away
happen um it would just work slightly
better or the same no difference
and we're leaking just a little bit of
per here a little bit of per there a
little bit of per everywhere that very
obnoxious
we just need to make it like 30%
faster actually you know there's
something I want to check as well
because we might even have to I want to
see how much more we have to optimize it
than I currently think
so if I
do that P3
Horizon how much lower does it get if I
do this
effect practice has a massive
effect is it all in misk
let's optimize for this
case and then we'll go from
there we don't want to do little
optimizations if we need to do big
optimizations
here no 10% is in here
okay how about
here just like leaks a little bit of per
here a little bit of per there a little
bit of per
everywhere really
well no this one's actually fine okay so
this loss you know maybe we can compile
this to make it a little bit
faster but it looks like we are mainly
leaking perf
here hang on how is this not all of
it how is this not all of it where are
we leaking 20% additional per
is that should not take any time so
let's figure out what's
wrong buffer is going to e even faster
isn't that crazy
yeah okay so somehow this stupid block
of code that should not be taking up
anything is taking up
133% that is a lot
I don't know if you saw on Discord but I
tried
TCH 2.6 and I get a 60k speed
up already did it my
friend uh did you change anything on the
box I didn't change anything on any of I
don't think I changed anything on box
two or anything for you but I did ship I
shipped like a Dev uh new Dev build
puffer tank files for uh torch
26 I think that that's specific though
to action sampling so that's not going
to be across everything that's just
going to be across like specific types
of
any reason not to merge what PR yeah the
reason not to merge a PR is I haven't
seen a PR oh look at
this this is doing
okay for
I'm sketched merging that into
2 if you merge if you do it to Dev I'll
PR if you do it to Dev I'll merge it
instantly
generally merging stuff just like YOLO
merging stuff to the main branch just
makes my life hard because inevitably
there's like some case where it crashes
an M or something and then I have to
stop what I'm doing and like go fix 20
frantically before like it impacts
somebody who really should not be
impacted by it
we've got lots of cool discussion in
group chats now private group Chats on
just juggling things with all the the
release stuff it's cool I think the post
will at least do pretty well for Pokemon
which is nice to see I think
uh that guy will
have see the problem is now even though
I have his name and it's all public like
it's still going to be that guy forever
cuz it's what the freaking Discord is
um yeah this is
awesome do he have followers yet oh yeah
he's getting some followers he started
at zero today it's at
45 that's a little start on
X I always say that X is mandatory for
ML researchers
all
right that's enough chatting for a bit
so it's so obnoxious the way that this
is so reward block
MP reward
Block
block now we can do this computation on
the
GPU and uh we will not be stuck
exp. reward
block values
again I think there was some index IND
in
crap shouldn't
be shouldn't be any indexing
crap contiguous block
I guess we just start putting stuff on
GPU we going have to test a couple
things
actions the thing is these are already
on on the GPU aren't
they believe
worse I actually kind of want to test
this separately before I do this because
this could be this could be a big
mistake if I screw this up
retweet and mostly converting to the
original as
well okay so this is a 1.1 1.1 mil right
and remember we we're going to
try we're going to try putting all this
stuff on the GPU and we're going to see
what
problem I'm almost sure the torch
doesn't have that
I'm going to just borrow this for now
and then we'll hope that we don't break
I think this will be the wrong
order but
uh F
order
has no attribute andem Che itself
and this is slow as
[ __ ] that is so slow God that is awful
why why does that even exist if it's
going to be that slow
I don't think there's a fast GPU sword
right is that a
this two
right let's just add them this
below
nump lovely
received
okay
H the transpose function is different
this is do
bxs do2 self.
device that's CU we're are indexing the
same
way
right so next
what we do
block right this is the thing that I
wanted to try
so put these on
device put these on
oh
yeah it's faster
right just taking this off of the just
doing this on GPU this is now
now let's see where the other P the
other uh computers leaking I think it's
all here now
right I think 7% or whatever in the uh
the main loss
function and then the rest of it here
right yeah about there 7 percentage 8%
something like that now all of our
leaking all the leak is right
here of course we're going to break some
synchronization but we'll have to fix
that finally got around to working on
graphics for impulse Warriors added some
Trails for players and projectiles
having trouble making edges the map have
a bloom glowing effect but maybe icons
for weapons all I need to add what do
you think and you made a website let's
o
okay hey these projectile icons are a
nice Edition
it's got something some fancy weapon it
looks
like where are the weapon
icons oh maybe I need to add those okay
I don't know I
mean I still think you could come up
with some sort of creative Shader for
this that would make it look really
good like pretty much all of these
weapons are just going to be like
particle effects
like you can probably just find some
cool
shaders couldn't find any icons where
are you looking
this I think you want the ones without
backgrounds on
them it's just generally where you look
you kind of have to do some digging
around to find artists that you like and
then see like what stuff they have
indexing okay I'm going to have to look
at
somehow I mean there are a lot of things
you can do there right
I mean look what they do right they
literally just did
like they just have some Bloom on stuff
with a bunch of shard sharp angles and
render the uh and render stuff using
outlines
right I think that you could probably do
something pretty similar to this without
too too much difficulty I mean there's
all sorts of stuff you can do like um
for instance you can do shaders to like
Ripple the environment when shots hit
and
stuff I'm going to be right back back
let me use the restroom I got to ban
this bot
first I'll be right
back 35%
leak 8% just an index
in which means
something for. ca. synchron what
happens nothing
right it's still going to be
8% 7%
this
slower much
slower interesting
slower maybe not hang
on experience. sort training
maybe you just have to do to
them let's see I remember pych having
this issue before but I want to see if
they fixed it
idx okay still of data to transfer
ideally you don't want to do
this yeah still just a slow okay you
don't want to you do not want to do
this it's a massive freaking am amount
of
data why doesn't this totally Crush
performance with the observations
actually you would think it would
right e
patch Ops are much bigger than the
values and we have to do the same
indexing operation don't
we how does that somehow not Crush
performance when this does crush
is I guess maybe the answer is that it
kind of
does that's probably where most of the
overhead comes from right
comes from
this we're just at a point where um
things are so so fast that this indexing
operation is
just doing what I think it's
doing I'm pretty darn sure that this is
literally just
here might be time to pay the piper on
this design
decision okay so here we have our IND
all kind of have to figure out the
trajectory segments thing now don't
we I've been putting this off for like a
year it's a pain in the
I guess we'll draw this out this will be
pretty informative anyways a couple
people
online
so it's a
blueprint so the problem that we have at
the moment
right when we collect
observations let's do the full thing we
get
like we get
indices like Z One 2
three
four okay and then this is at time
T this is the environment
index and what's the other thing that we
store
it oh yeah we also Store Flat
index so the sample
order so what we do with
this is we
go 0 one two
three actually let me just let's just
make this
better so let's do instead of zero we do
one five three
seven
this
okay and
then just do
like we get
like
zero three one
initially we make a big table like
this and now this has eight numbers 0
one two
huh and then it's G to have
the uh environment
index so this is going to
one
three
3 1 4 and then we put up the end we put
t
Okay and then what we can do is we can
sort this
thing uh we can sort this thing
basically
by believe it's this row and then this
row
right yeah we sort this by this row and
this row so what we want to get out of
this
is that data at the end of the
day so we
get what we do
zero one t
Z
one we
do I guess it should have been Z
0 why it's so confusing Z T
three
one Z or
t t okay so now we have these in
order by environment ID and clearly uh
the important thing here is that these
are grouped up
so technically if we give if we keep
these indices we should be able to to
detect these
boundaries and uh and use
this still tricky because with the
lsdm you have to go across
so I mean we split this up into
segments oh but we the key assumption
here is that the segments are going to
end up being pretty
long
right at least reasonably so
array the sorted indices
array I think we get it don't we
oh and I messed this up as well didn't
I where's the is there an
eraser yeah this should not be like this
this is you have to actually Arc sort
the
indices
so what it this is
actually
Four this is
zero is
I
stupid
[Music]
zero no this is fine
or this initial one
is
zero six and so on and so forth so you
do have the indices in here the indices
tell you where to get your data
from how much
of this indexing is coming from each of
these other
things much of this indexing is coming
from each of these other things
now still expensive that's still 11%
compute 12%
compute mean we can't do this on the GPU
right now there's iteration
here that actually screws us over for
the values as well doesn't
does very difficult to make this thing
fast
be it shouldn't be
right the observations in the network
are doing way more work than
this so it's really just about
optimizing this thing because I the
fundamental amount of work being done
here is not very large
kind of a few different problems with
how we're doing this isn't there aren't
there
so and there are a few different
problems
nuts kind of want to solve both of these
in one Fell Swoop
all you have to do you're looking for
boundaries
right what are my options
here I already have do I have all these
quanties on the GPU
already or do I
not I have everything but the index
tensor on GPU and the index tensor needs
to go to GPU anyways
there's no way to store this stuff
continuously in the first place
right no you'd have to make additional
assumptions how many additional
assumptions would you have to
make it's kind of
tough like me supporting the
asynchronous is starting to
limit the ways in which I can collect
data
right for something like GPU Drive
you're going to get all these little
segments
you don't know from the GetGo how you're
going to want to
batch so the best thing you can do is
store them flat to begin
with right I think I kind of already
have the
this you could have a per agent buff
that doesn't help you though because
there's a map size to that that can be
highly
variable it can be highly variable for
every type of M usually not even just
for specialized ones that doesn't help
on environment no you really can't
improve on this very much at
all what this indexing
operation that has to happen
you would think this operation should be
able to be
I think we need to go check this out
don't
2x it
is let's just make sure there's not a
speed make sure but yeah that's
fine same speed
is this
flat viewed as 1 D
I think that there you're unlikely to be
able to improve this
right it should already be paralyzed
efficiently
doesn't matter if you use an intro long
it seems
NPI indexing very very slow for large
tensors uh if by comparison though if we
were to
do if we did
this would the result be
different yes they
would GPU is
faster for large
tensors is slower for small tensors
this hi that is interesting so the big
batches it is faster on the
GPU by an order of magnitude
still it goes down if you have smaller
batches
this is still
information have some ideas I'll be
right
here I think that what happened with
this is before I was measuring indexing
for and uh I had smaller
batches so it was more uh effective to
do it
on in numpy but now it's faster to do
it in p in P torch it looks
it's actually
faster it is actually
faster and index select is faster than
slice here as
well but it's not that that is not the
case
these so uh let's just do this one real
quick
four okay uh torches cleaned up their
indexing a whole
bunch it looks to me like torches
actually improved their indexing a whole
bunch so we
[Music]
can possibly rely on that
Logics
device and you do store right
we just do
this we do
do return
action
you you do have to
pass actions back of CPU
T float
has no attribute item
aha we get speed
increase we do get a speed increase
here but we will see what that is from I
think that is good news
how's the uh the post doing by the way
on uh the Pokemon post doing
tonight
95 not
bad definitely not
NP uh and then actually I think we can
delete all
this
right doesn't need any of this oh that's
way way nice
nice Advantage MP I think we still need
that
one otherwise reward block
I think that we still need these but the
rest of them are gone get rid of
this hang on we do need to know we still
need to have buffers allocated right for
is there a way to cut the memory
allocations
out we can look at that potentially
after um um I think we'll just do this
for
now so I'm sure this
same we now have
28% of this overhead inside of
custom
28% how would we do
here we now have this index on GPU we
need to do
torch
lovely this no longer takes any time at
all this indexing no longer takes any
time so we are making forward progress
here
adj just this transfer how much does it
take
so let's just do for
synchronize I think we need it here for
a device transfer that's blocking
133% 14% so this it's a lot of compute
right here
this
aha that is faster by a
lot freaking pie
torch see
something nice
probably doesn't do anything
right no that doesn't do anything we can
just leave it as a
string it's a single call it's not in
the
loop it's not going to have any overhead
there we go so three % total right here
3%
this this is 15
16 lot of compute wasted here
lot of compute wasted how about flatten
mostly but mostly now we have it down to
this we've gotten rid of a lot of
the there are a couple problems
here so
this is just too much data to process I
think on
um this is just too much data
fundamentally to process on a
CPU isn't
it let me think is this too much data to
process should it
be should it be too much data to process
what type of steps per second do I think
I should be able to get on this
operation 128
numbers I do this all the time for
puffer Libs
environments I'm able to get this at
millions of steps per
second there's no way that this is
slower than breakout that one it's like
10 million steps for
the problem is it's done
synchronously so even if I get 10
million steps per
second yeah that's still going to be
rough like this n here is 10 million
steps per second actually right that's
still going to be rough
okay what other options do I
have so blocking
operation I actually need to call Cuda
synchronize
here for safety right
ay it's tough I think you've probably
seen by now the
uh Pokemon stuff is
live we
go there you go he's probably gotten
some followers right yeah there we go
73 perfect
what do we do with
this there's no way in hell we can do
this on the GPU right unless I write a
chal uh
ah hold
on hold on does it even make sense to do
that
wait this might be the thing that
finally makes puffer need a custom thrn
this thing is going to compute
advantages the size of advantages
thing yeah this was a kernel I
think I think this is finally the thing
I've not actually done any
Cuda I've not done any Cuda at
all I mean I've been this is also kind
of a really bad time for me to have to
pick something new up like that I'd like
to
actually this is a really bad time to
have to do this
with all the other stuff going
meantime well I'm not totally screwed
here
right hang on I'm not totally screwed
this is the pessimistic
case right here
if I run regular breakout right
now what do we
get let
here has no
attribute
this okay that's a little faster than
before isn't
it just a little bit but it is a little
just a little hair
now
what now we
more two M two
workers 24 m per work
million that's slower than before the
hell that doesn't make sense
one
oh let see
1.1
mil let's look at the distributions
here forward
9% 9%
M 29 uh 20%
Miss spend the extra time
learn it's just a little bit of
overhead 10% here we have a bit more
than 10% overhead which is a bit
concerning though
right so let's just run these both for
seconds I'm going to run them both for
seconds and just going to do a little
bit of just janky manual
profiling same thing here and then we'll
compare
so we spent 5 seconds in forward six
seconds and
forward 4 seconds and copy 3 seconds and
copy seconds and train 18
seconds board is 4 seconds 13% 3 seconds
very good seconds learn 11 seconds learn
Miss is 3
seconds 2 seconds Miss
we
spent just 3 seconds in
Miss 6 seconds in
this this would seem then there's only
10% overhead so why is it slower than
up so I guess we'll just have to fix
that and then we'll see
uh 6 seconds
good uhoh
well this does way
worse let's see if I've broken data or
if it's just the parameters the double
number
I don't think we can have completely
broken
learning that is still doing
processing
off 20 48m 1
one do this for comparison
that makes a huge difference doesn't
it it's
pretty small speed increase verus what I
had before on this but still noticeable
and this one matches right yeah this one
matches very
nicely
so now the only difference is P30
also I believe before it
was we can see the
700 to 900 so we've
mostly mostly closed the
Gap oh we should run this just for the
heck of it though just to make sure we
didn't break it
similar another 14% that we can save off
the environment if we get a bigger end
batch size working
or lower overhead
bindings 14% is kind of surprisingly
large for how fast breakout should
d8
perfect boom
matches see what did we just squeeze out
of this thing
oh yeah we squeezed a little out of
it
extra
perc
5% very
a
900k 900k
not fast enough 900k too
slow 900k is way too
time is it
5:18
maybe I just fiddle with this a
5:18 maybe I just fiddle with this a little bit I can throw it into Gro to
little bit I can throw it into Gro to
just see what it would do I have no
experience writing
Fels I've been wanting to get into that
at some
point I do plenty of lowle Dev
wrapper
okay is that
ah I see actually so this is a problem
because if you don't have a
GPU it doesn't run correctly
pile
both is
right oh wait do I have profiling
on hang on I just saw that
that custom is
lower lower overhead
here but uh still there's a
on I think it is fully parallel across
row isn't it
Crossroads yeah cuz the Min and the max
I can
compute uh I can compute these cleanly
this code actually doesn't look that bad
this looks fairly similar to what I'm
doing
already which is kind of what I figured
you have to be a little careful with the
parallelism and I'm sure debugging is a
pain in the ass thought debugging is
already a pain in the ass what I'm
doing yeah this was kind of what I was
expecting though like when you're
already doing low-l
Dev it doesn't really matter if it's
like you're doing CPU or GPU or what
like you're using really the same
stuff it's
527 what you guys think we write a
through to Colonel or we attempt
to never written these
before I this would be kind of cool
though I think we do
it rest one more time real quick and
then um we back in a minute we'll have a
good half hour 40 minutes I think let me
just double check on uh they do have to
go to dinner at some point so let me
double check on that and then uh if I
have time we will write this Colonel
right now and if not we'll write it
later tonight or tomorrow right be right
back
all right I got like 20 30 minutes to
just start on this I want to make this
as easy on myself as possible though
before I start so we're going to
do we're going to do
float BD
Max Min and Max
okay min
let's do this on vpu as
well
Min an
item Max
okay just do bstd min bstd max
go yeah that's about the same speed as
before as it should be so good now we
have
okay okay let's see there's an implicit
bind that's fine
C I'm going to have to check all this
mess I'm sure
synchronize
and let me try this
return
something it does
W
basically all these are going to go to
uh Duda I guess
and uh you don't have to pass this
because you compute this in the other
function
right
advantages advantages
CPU or whatever something like
that syron
okay now we'll be able to fix a lot of
this as
well Middle with
this and you don't have to compile this
or anything it just uh
Cuda you need to C A toolkit don't
you that sucks
I think it's going to be easier to just
get the
um the container I'll just pytch ship
these so that they're
pre-built I don't know
actually but we are going to have to
deal with this
kind of annoying that um we'll have to
redo some setup but it's
where's the darn list of them where you
can find these
easily I guess I just swap it to deel
instead of
[Music]
runtime they're not that big of uh
there's not that big of a size
difference is there oh no there is adds
a couple gigs that's
annoying we should have this in our
container anyways though I've gotten
burned by this before I don't know why I
did why I decided to get
so we'll just fiddle with this for now
I'll come back later I'm going to have
to do a little bit of porting stuff and
then we'll go from there
i' say we've gotten like reasonably
decent performance on first day tweet of
Pokemon 107 5.7k
views has it done anything on
honestly I could see myself just jamming
some
Cuda on some point here
wouldn't that be funny if we just like
ludicrously
optimized we like figure out what puffer
model we like to use for everything and
we just ludicrously optimized
it 10 million step per second
training I think for that we'd have to
literally like yeah the the whole
training Loop would have to go to cudar
though the
thing any of the Python looping is just
slow
I don't think it's worth the effort to
really do that though because very
quickly our models are going to get
bigger little bit bigger no not even
huge just like as soon as you go to a
million maybe there's still performance
benefits I don't
all right and then it's
puffer
depths puffer depths right
fun we break um oh yeah
7,000 look at that that's kind of nice
basically all I want to do for right now
is get this container to run and then
see if we have
nbcc make sure we get
something for
function c advantage.
c
and
my plugins back
go all
right let's
canot
access
either the array has no attribute is
Cuda what did I screw
go this is
Cuda good
that oh
there incompatible
arcs oh yeah also we forgot to do
well the Min and the max are
backwards let's fix that before we
forget and have L to pay for
types are
supported tensor tensor
incompatible hang on
what incompatible function
arguments all right I got to run I will
fix this after dinner um for folks
watching if you're interested in all the
stuff I do you want to get involved with
RL you're interested in puffer
everything's on puffer doai star the
repo to help us out really helps a ton
join the Discord if you want to get
involved and follow on X for more RL
news and content thanks and